よろしくお願いします
今日は 今日はダンマパダの説明になります
うんと 番目ってなんか違うような気がしますけど
番だいぶ長くこの間説明していただいて
大体と同じですから ちょっと違うところ
そうですか そうですね
じゃあ番にします Yassa
asava parinhina ahare ca anissito suññato animitto ca vimukho yassa gocharo
akase va sakuntanam padam tesam durannayam.えーと
本当はと一緒にやった方が良かったかもしれませんだけど Yassa
asava parinhina ahare ca anissito suññato animitto ca vimukho yassa gocharo
akase va sakuntanam padam tesam durannayam.この偈もこの阿羅漢という境地ってどういうものであそうかっていう
ことの説明なんですけど
経典ではね この悟りは何か
阿羅漢とは何かとか説明しようとはかなりの努力はしています
しかし 基本的にはもうアナッカータンという言葉でも形容してますから
言葉にならない 説明はできないっていうことはそのままなんです
それでも人々はそれでどういうことかとね
まあ修行もしないのに
仏教の真理は理解しないのに
最初にもそれを教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
で 仏教を知り尽くしてる人にしても説明はできないことで
悟りに達した人以外は知らないんですね
じゃあ知った人説明すればいいかというと
言葉がないんだからね
だからお釈迦様も説明できないと
して この説明できないことは説明するんですね
だからよくあるのはこの説明できないことの説明なんです
それからもう一つ この否定形を使う方法もあります
それで人々はまんまと騙されるだけで
仏教から見る理解能力にはならないんです
否定形で使う説明方法っていうのは
何かあるものをね 人間が知ってるものを見せて
それがないと言うんですね
なんとなく分かったような気がするだけ
大体経典に出てくる説明っていうのは
そういう何々がないっていう説明だけなんですね
一つ例を出しますけど
だから生きることは全て苦であると
それはもう絶対的真理で
もうどう頑張ってもこれ変わりませんよと
私たちは分かってる苦しみもあるし
楽だと思ってるものも調べてれば苦しみであるし
精密に見ても苦以外ないんだと
涅槃っていうのは苦しみがないことであると
なんか分かったように
だからじゃ分かりませんよ
だから我々のこの妄想にゴチャゴチャ絡んでる頭はちょっとまああのストップさせるんで
それだけなんです スタンガンでやられたような感じで
カチっと思考が麻痺するんです
もう答えられないんですね
で それならこの まあ生きることは苦であるということは理解しなさいとまず
それはできるんですね
我々に経験しているものだからね
で ですから 人はどの程度で苦しみをわかっているのかというところで
まあこの苦しみがないことであると
もうなんとなく  分かったような気がする
で さらにさらに精密に一切
まあ諸行は無常苦であると分かったところで
もうやっぱりこの苦は苦以外に何もないんだから
これはアカンやと で 気持ちになって
で それでも極限に苦に対するもう厭というね
ことが生まれてくるんですね
それはまあ生そのものに対する厭を離れることであって
それで心がガクッと解脱という境地に変わってしまうんです
で それ以上言葉ないんだから
その人はそれっきり黙ってるんです
涅槃が何せ探そうともしないし
人に教えてあげようともしないし
だからこの否定形で説明すると
まあ なんとか分かる で
それしか方法なかったみたいですね
だからこちらも同じスタイルで説明しています
ヤッサ アーサワ パリッケーナ
アーサワっていうのは煩悩ですね
煩悩は全部なくなっているんだと
で この前とこちら違うというのは
前の偈は三日夜ですね
蓄えですね 今度は煩悩ですね
アーサワ アーサワは流れるという
漏れるという単語なんですね
私たちは眼耳鼻舌身というね
五感がありまして そこで外の世界とコンタクトを取ってるんですね
世界っていうのは幻想で世界あるわけじゃないんです
ただ この体にいろんなものが触れているだけ
目に形が触れる 耳に音が触れる
そこでこの見えたものは桜の木ですか
仏像ですかとかね そんなのをこちらの頭の中で
まあ幻想するもので みんなに同じこと見えるっていうことはないんです
どの程度で触れるのかっていうことのだけですね
じゃあこの猫が仏像を見て
どんな猫の目にどんな程度の光が触れるかと
これはわからないでしょうに
色は見えるかどうかもわからないし
また 猫の瞳っていうのはもう時計と同じくずっと変わっていくんだからね
で 12時昼間になってくるとすごく細いし
これどんどん広くなって
夜見ると目いっぱい瞳なんですね
で だから猫は光はどうやって撮っているかっていうことはね
我々はわからないし だから猫には何何を見えるかっていうことは知らない
我々はね 私たちにしてみたって
他人にどのように見えるかわからないでしょうね
だから いろんなもの 私と一緒にいる方々はね
あれってすごく綺麗でしょうねとか
綺麗でしょうかねと私思ったりもしますけど
やっぱりよく考えてみればみんなによく見えないんですね
で まあ今眼鏡かけてますけど
眼鏡かける前のはもう 2 0で視力ありましたから
で そこまで結構かなり遠くまで結構明確に見えるんです
なんて綺麗だ 夜の照明とかね
みんな綺麗見て 私のは別々別々に見て
間に隙間見えますから
だから何ですかと だけど私もなんかぼけっと見てみると
結構繋がっていてね ああ
結構綺麗だ だから それぞれ視力によりますからね
おそらく鳥たちには全然綺麗に見えないでしょうね
で それからね 目がね 受け取る光の波長もね
それぞれ変わってるし
私たちも知らない知らないうちに色盲になったりしてみるしね
もう本当に色全部見えるかどうかちょっとわからないんですね
お医者さんは一応テキスト持ってますけど
我々は基本的な 3 原色チェックするだけで
もっと色のトーンがね
ものすごいありますからね
で だから自分が作った世界
自分の世界なんですね
これはもう誰とも共有することはできませんし
私も色見本見て綺麗ですねと
隣の人そうですね すごい
もうこれってたまげたな
綺麗です それぞれ何を見てるかとわからないんです
だから私に何で綺麗でしょうかと聞いちゃうと
私はテクニカル説明しかしないんです
で まあクリスマスになってくるとね
もうかなりイルミネーションありますからね
前はね 東京でも腕を振って来て
丸の内の方でもやってましたけどね
今はあまりないみたいですね
キリスト教はどんどん地方に行ってて
地方だったらむちゃくちゃもう派手ですけどね
で 綺麗です 私はやっぱりではなくて
テクニカル的にね 技術的に何をやっているのかと
別に綺麗とは思わないんでね
技術は上手だなと 結構苦労しているなとかね
わかると その分人間の努力は評価したいんですね
結構ひどい目に遭いながら
この間東京のどこでしたっけ？えっとえっとえっと
レインボーブリッジとかあるところでね
何か有名なショーのイルミネーションあるって言って
まあ見たら なんでこんな宣伝する割にはこれかいと
もうテレビで派手に宣伝してやったんですね
人々も行く 私たちも道を聞きながら
あのどこ出た あの場所
え？お台場 ただなんかもうちょっとした大きな柱ですけど
コーン型でね それでそこでまあ LED の光ずっとつけてるだけで
まあ綺麗は取り出したことではなかったんですけど
でも私はまあこれはすごい手の込んだ
もう作品やと 何やというと
この LED をずっと回って回って
柱に全部この柱丸めて回っていて
そこでこの変化することがコンピューターでプログラミングして
いろいろ何か富士山のようなもの
雪が降っているようなことも
星が落ちるのもいろいろ映像が流れるようにしているんですね
そこは機械的には無理ですから
おそらくかなりかなり苦労して
で コンピューター制御ですね
あとでここまでできるのかと思ったら
できる方法あるんだと
で あの柱そのものがコンピューターのスクリーンのように設定すれば
このどんな位置でどんな光が光るべきかということは
まあコマンドプログラムということはそんなに難しくはないので
そういうことかと  それでも結構結構お金かかって
結構能力はね プログラミングをエンコーディングするというのは
かなり工夫してやらなくちゃいけないので
それで評価するだけでね
見てもらえば別に だからこの見える世界っていうのは
我々自分で作る 聞こえる世界も我々自分で作る
味わう世界も何でもかんでも自分で作る世界ですね
で 料理にいろんな味付けをして食べる人々にとってはね
インド料理 フランス料理
中華料理を食べる人々にとっては
寿司って何がおいしいでしょうかと
よくわからないでしょうに
ただの生肉ですからね
わさびつけている だからそこは日本人の舌では別な世界が現れるし
かなり味付けて食べる人々にとっては
またそれでそれなりのベストな世界が現れるんです
そういうことで この私たちは自分が知ってるんだ
だからもう何かある文句あるのかと態度を取ってますけど
結局は何知ってるのかと
自分だけの世界に閉じ込められているだけなんですね
それが正しいと全く証明することは成立することもできませんし
しかし推測すると みんなみんなそれぞれ自分の世界を作っているんだから
だから私だけ正しくなる必要はないし
私と違ったものね 一人が寿司がおいしいと言うんだから
もう一人がこんなのはまずい
食べられないんだと 生臭いんだと
と言って ものすごくもう食欲もなくなる場合ありますよ
突然インド人とかアフリカの人にとか出してみてください
刺身とかは 逃げると思いますよ
テレビでそれを見たのはアフリカのどこかにすごい田舎の若い子がね
ものすごい食べる年なんですね
すごくかわいらしい体格もいいし
若者で まあこれは軽々とキロ食べるだろうと思う体格で
だからあの年の人を見ると
やっぱり食べて食べてほしいんでしょうしね
これを食べて食べていること
大人にとってはね 食べられる大人にとってそれは楽しいしね
若者は元気いっぱいでね
もう何でもパクパク骨まで何でも食っちゃうとね
しかしこの子はあのタイの丸焼き
丸焼きではない タイそのものの姿で刺身にしてね
結構テレビですからね
まあかなり金かけて腕を振るって作ってやったものですけど
こいつは涙流しながら逃げたこと家に入らないんで
テレビカメラ追っかけて外でもう泣いてるんですね
あんな大型の若者が もう呼ぶことは全くできませんで
それでもしょうがなくあれをどかして
で やっと来てもらったんで
それは何食べてかというと
芋とかね サツマイモとか
だからこの あの子は頭がおかしいんですかね
間違ってるんですかね
そんなことも言えないでしょうね
かわいそうで 美味しいなのに
こんなこれわからないなとかね
いうことも我々にとってできないでしょうしね
だから自分が正しいってことは成り立たないし
だから他人が正しいってことも成り立たないし
結局はようわからないという
誰も誰も人間っていうのは
生命はね 自分の認識に
で 幻想世界に凝り固まっていて
真理はわからないんだと
だから わかったければ
この幻想を作るプロセスを学ぶしかないんですね
瞑想っていうのはそういうことなんですね
どうやって目が情報対象と呼んでですね
データを取って どうやってそこをごちゃごちゃプログラミングして認識するのかと
そうすると よく我々にわかることは
同じものを見て 時々綺麗やと思ったりして
面白くないと思ったりして
めんどくさいと同じことにしてね
思っちゃうでしょうに
だからそこを瞑想している人ならわかるんですね
突然花を見ると綺麗やと思いますけど
ちょっと見ていると別にどうってことないって面白くないっていうことになってくるでしょうに
そうなるはずがないでしょ
物は変わったわけじゃないんだから
そんな早く だからこちらの中のプログラミングプロセスなんですね
それがあまりにも果てに早く変わっていくんですね
それでアースは流れる
流れるもの で アースは日本訳は漏ですからね
漏れるというね 煩悩のことなんですけど
なんで漏というね 漏れるという漢字使っているのかと
そこでものを見ていると
欲やら怒りやらそこで割り込んでくるんですね
だから見てならないという意味じゃないんです
仏教では 見てはならない
聞いてはならないと話にならないんだから
それだったら で 見ている過程で
どことなく欲が漏れてくるんですね
心の中に だから自分が作った自分だけのこの凝り固まった世界は
もう欲でかなり汚染されていて
怒りで汚染されていて
無知で汚染されているんですね
そこはどこから来た？別に花から来たわけじゃないんです
聞いている音 音楽から来たわけじゃないんです
では こちらで初めから欲があったという
そうでもないんですね
花を見て音楽を聴いてから欲が生まれたんだから
だから 物があって認識するというところに
煩悩というものは漏れてくるんですね
漏れるんだからアースはと言うんですね
だからお釈迦様がそこで修理するのは
この漏れるところ 漏れないように修理しましょうと
で それがマダメゾで 我々はある程度で成長していくと
認識システムがしっかりできていて
ありのままに見られるようになると
だからありのままにっていうのは専門用語なんですよ
術用語なんです ただの単語じゃないんです
如実に見るということ
如実にするという いわゆる幻想は作りませんと
幻想を作るんだけど もうすぐ現れますけど
そこに何も漏れてないんです
で ありのままに見るために
見る人だけ無常を発見するんですね
ありのままに見ると空を発見してくるんですね
無我を発見できるんです
だから ありのままに見る世界っていうのは
人に言っても理解してくれないんです
で 皆様に仏像見えるかもしれませんだけど
それありのままに見るとこのものやと言っても
それは理解できないんです
あの猿さんに鏡を見せて
鏡の裏に何もないんだよと
どうやって教える で 私たちにしても
鏡の中で映像が見えるんだから
ものすごくおかしいでしょうに
あれが鏡の中で見えることが
鏡の中は何もないのに
何もない ただの板ですからね
まあ今どうやって作るかわかりませんだけど
昔は高級鏡はね 銀でしたからね
まあただのガラス板ですからね
今はガラスではなく すごくプラスチック板でも紙でもできますしね
今紙もありますね 鏡効果の
では なのに中見れるでしょうに
これっておかしいでしょうに
そのおかしいからくりが常に起きてるんです
我々は騙されるのは鏡だけですけど
他の世界で見事に騙されているんです
今 どんどん 3D 映画も出始めてるでしょう
前はかなり珍しいものでしたけど
今はどんどん今家庭でも 3D 映画見られるようにもうなりつつでしょうしね
まだそんなにソフトウェアよくできてないんですけど
一応テレビは今マーケットに出す計画なんですね
あと 2  3ヶ月で で そんなに高くもないしね
普通の値段で めんどくさいのは眼鏡かけなくちゃいけない
眼鏡が高いんですよ 腹が立ちます
1万円です だってあれ家族でみんな喧嘩しながら奪い合いながら使うとね
壊れるでしょうに だからもう買いまくるしかない
これ腹が立ちますけど
子供2人ならばせいぜい 4枚ぐらい
4枚  6枚ぐらい買いておかない
買って置いておかないと
もう で まあ夫婦の 2つだけではそれで十分ですけど
子供がいる場合は結構これはまあ大変なことになると思います
眼鏡かければ画像はね
3次元で目の前にあるとあるんだからね
だからそういうことを見ても
やっぱりもう視覚だけでも幻想であるということでしょう
だから同じ機能 眼鏡外して普通に見ると見ても同じことですから
起きているのは しかし音
について 香り 味についてそういう研究もできない
まあ音については まあ音を作る位置がね
まあこの目は脳は計算するんだだからね
左耳と右耳の音が取る時の時間の差で
で もう引き算足し算でわかりませんだけど
脳は結構計算して もうこちらから来ている
これこちらから来ていると
ドラムセットが右側にあって
もうもう例えばギタリストは左側のやっているとすぐわかります
で ギターの音が右耳左耳に入って
次に右耳に入るんだからね
この差 この信じられないぐらい時間的には信じられないぐらい微妙ですからね
しかし 脳がそれを知っていて
あの左にはこれぐらい強さで効いて
こちらはこれぐらい強さで効いて
これから時間遅れがあって
引き算すれば あ 二メートル三メートル
一メートルぐらい離れてるんだと
より左側やと いうすごい計算が起きてますけど
まあそこまではないんだけど
一応今まあ音もそうやってね
ステレオでね 音出る場合もそのカラクリで作ってますけど
あれほどはうまくいってないんですね
だからこの常に我々の感覚の中でね
幻覚は受けてますけど
私たちはそれなかなか知らない
研究することもできない
それからこの身体の場合は
仏教ではね まあこれは簡単に言ってますけどね
体で大したことを感じないんだと
感じるのは温度と硬さだけよと
肉体で感じるのは 熱と硬さ
温度といっても しかし
私たちにとってはそんなもんじゃないでしょう
体に触れるということはすごい世界ですから
なまれ感とかね ふわふわしているとかね
すべすべしているとか
いろいろ言ってますけどね
全て幻想なんですね 幻覚なんです
実際感じるのは硬さと熱
この硬さの差でふわふわしているとかね
これギザギザですよとかね
これサラサラですよとかね
いろいろこれぶよんぶよんしていますよとかね
だからぶよんぶよんしているよと
何かね あの 例えばね 日本ではないんですけど
あのベッドはウォーターベッドとかあるでしょ
それ指で押してみたら硬く感じるんですね
まあ本当は硬く感じるんですね
で 押してみるともう一回
時間ずれて硬く感じるんですね
その差を計算 ぶよんぶよんしてる
一旦指に触れた感触がまたちょっと減ってまた触れてくるんです
それが何回触れるかっていうことなんです
だから あ これは気持ちいいや
これなら気持ちよく楽に寝れそうやとかね
何なのかと どこへ行っても体感じるのは硬さと熱だけということに終わってるんです
板の上に寝ようか 空気マットの上に寝ようが関係ないんです
だから世界はもうただいかに楽楽しくしようかなというね
幻想を育てる世界ばっかりですけど
この機能は何なのかって誰もあまり研究したりはしないしね
はい  そういうことでありのままに寝て見る場合はどのように見られるかということを俗世間にとってはね
まあ説明しても全然理解しないでしょう
幻覚の方がよろしいと
と思ってるんですね そこで幻覚は現実だと思ってるんだから
それで無明ですね 間違ったんだから愚痴ですね
だから無明が無知が働いていて
本物だからやっぱり欲しいか嫌いかまた出てくるんですね
だからこの無知のせいで
そういう要らん汚れが心に割り込むんですね
人間の問題はそれであると発見したのはお釈迦様であって
宗教家に言えば あなたは神様に供養していないでしょうにと
いきなりそんな話を 神様にちゃんと決まってる日で供養しなくちゃいけないでしょう
インドではいろんな釘とかね
いろんなやり方で神に何か供養するというね
それで人間の問題解決すると思っているんですね
人間の失敗は煩悩によりでしょうね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみなどなど煩悩があるんだから
我々はさらにさらに苦しむ羽目になっているんです
我々は何か体に触れると怒ったりもする
あるいは気持ちいいと思っても
欲をそそったりもする
感じたのは硬さと熱さだけだから
これなんで怒るんですかね
なんで欲張るんですかねとか
だから感じられるのは硬さと熱さだけだと
だけだと発見した人にとってはバカバカらしくてどうってことないんですね
煩悩が生まれないんですね
煩悩が生まれないと問題はありません
その人を怒らせることはできないんです
だから私たちはね 商売うまくいってないんだからといって
それで精神的に落ち込んだり
落ち入ったり 悪いこと散々まで怒ったり
最悪の状態に転がってしまいますね
どこまででも 学校でいじめられたって
タッチされたことでいじめられたっていうことは幻想幻覚でしょうね
現実じゃないんだから
具体的な何やったかいうと
もうこういうキモいと言われましたよと
いつでも言われているんだよと
ただの音だけなんですけど
そこはその人がどうプロセッシングするのかということで
もういじめになったり
どうったことない もうこいつらうるさいなと感じたりとかね
毎日見ているグループだから
何言われたって全然へっちゃらでいる子もいるし
[音楽]だから問題はこの自分たちの無知とこの無知の程度だと言ったってもよろしいし
で 無知があまりにも働いていると
かなり欲怒りが作ったりするんだからね
だから人間の問題はこの認識過程にあるものですということはね
ということで 仏教は無明は根本
根本原因と言えないんですけど
無明は基準にして全て仏教を語られているんです
で そのそれがいろいろみんなもう誤解したり
もうさらに誤解したりとかね
最悪なんで 人間の誤解を解くために
まさかさんは無明から無明は愛スタートって喋ってますけど
もう何だこれ 無明はどうやって生まれるのか
また余計なことを聞いたりとかね
だから他宗教ではこの人間の問題は知らないだけでは問題さえも知らないんですね
問題を発見したら解決策
だから問題さえもわかってないだから解決策あるわけでもないんですね
どこかで永遠の命になったらいいんじゃないかという思っちゃうんですね
だから永遠の命ってなりたしかない命
それぞれ命って何なのか説明しなくちゃいかんでしょ
それを研究しないんですね
それは研究不可能であると
それが神の世界であると
だったら永遠かないか分からないでしょうに
神が神が作ったものだから永遠である
だったら肉体は永遠になるはずでしょうに
だから本当は今はごまかして言ってないんだけど
元々このそのまま体で肉体の体で永遠になることを思っていたんです
キリスト教もそうなんです
イエスも思っていたのは
そのまんまでもう天国にいて永遠にいられるんだと
相当な無知で肉体に固執
執着でしょ もっと真の体になった方がいいんじゃないんですかね
我々にとっては自分の今の肉体はこれで十分ということもありますからね
だから問題はどこにあるのかさっぱりわかってないし
問題は何かともさっぱりわかってないし
その原因もわかってないし
したがって解決策わかるはずがないし
だから仏教の思想体が絶対的真理だと
これが違うと言える人っていうのは現れませんよと言った時点でバカになるだけ
その人は はい そこで説明が長すぎましたけど
阿羅漢っていうのは漏れるもの
で 漏れるということは
目でものを見て もう視覚が生まれる過程で視覚と一緒にそれ視覚まではさっと起こります
それからそれ認識するんですね
意で そこら辺でもう思い存分煩悩が割り込んでいるんです
で これ長い間起きてるものだから
この 働き 3つあるんですね
それぞれ専門用語で変わってますけど
例えば この見るたびに
聞くたびに 味わうたびに
いわゆる生きる瞬間瞬間で心が汚れていくでしょ
だからそうすると心は相当汚れが溜まってるんですね
今 欲で汚れている心を持っていて
ものを見たり聞いたりすると
その今すでにあった欲が次の認識に影響を与えるんです
だからどんな汚れが漏れるかっていうことを判断する前に
その前にあなたはどんな汚れを持っていたのかっていうこともチェックしなくちゃいけないんですね
欲の汚れがいっぱいあったならば
突然怒りの汚れが生まれないんです
だから私たちにはこの瞬時に気持ちを入れ替えることはできないんです
でしょ スイッチを入れるような感じで
赤青とかね それできません
悲しくなったら結構そこはもう引きずっちゃうんです
嫉妬が出てたらもう引きずってしまうんです
怒りができたらそれらの時間がそれ引きずってしまいます
欲が生まれても もう結構引きずってしまいます
若者が恋に落ちたら もう全部忘れてそこだけで引きずっていて
勉強もろくにできませんし
今までの友達とはもう置いておいて
この恋の世界だけでいたりして
そこで突然もう何て言いますか
この別れたら 相手がもういいや
もう付き合いやめますと
あ そうですか はい さようならと言って
またドアを開けて別の女の子を見て
あ こいつ この子可愛いんだけど
何とかしようってできますかね
できないでしょうに それ時間かかるんですね
その瞬間にできるならばね
喫茶店でね 女の人と喋っていて
ケンカになって もう別れますと
あ そう じゃあ君どう？全然これできないでしょ
その人出て立ち上がって行く前にも
次の人と友達になろうと頑張っているならばぴったしなんですけど
それだったら全然ほとんど問題ないんです
別れた人を悩ます必要ないし
この人を悩ます必要ないし
だからこの 何か見て聞いてとかね
煩悩が生まれる場合 どんな煩悩かということは決める前に
今前すでにどんな感情があったかということによって影響を与えます
影響働きはいろいろですけど
例えば欲の心があって
そこでもう嫌なもの情報を受けたりすると
いきなり怒ることはできないんですね
その代わりに あの情報によって欲の感情がどんどん下がっていくんです
怒りの情報 フル嫌な情報が入っているんだから下がっていって 0 になって
まあどうでもいいやと
面白くないという無知だけの煩悩になって
それから怒ってくるんです
美味しくご飯を食べていると
何か人が来て もう何か仕事の話とか
あるいは自分がやった何か別な嫌な聞きたくない話をいやいやまあいいや今ご飯食べていることとかって言って言ったりするでしょうね
それでも人はやめないで喋っているでしょうね
それでこっちが頑張って美味しくご飯を食べようと思っちゃいますが
味がどんどん気持ちが減っていくんですね
それでももう食べる気がなくなっちゃって
もう なんだこれって無知な状態に陥って
それから怒るんですね
毎日我々はそういうふうなシステムで生きているんです
ものすごく怒って気が立っている状態で
すごい美しいものを何か見てもね
もうもうワンちゃんが可愛いワンちゃんが来て
自分の方を見ておっぽおっぽ振っていたっても
あ なんて可愛いの！いきなり怒り消えません
怒ったままでワンちゃんの方見ているんです
見ているとどんどん怒りがどんどん減っていって
なんかバカバカらしくなっちゃって
まあしょうがない 可愛い可愛い
それからなんです だから
この波の形が別の波に変わる前
いきなり反対の波に変わらないんですね
怒りっていうのはものすごい攻撃的な波で
欲っていうのは執着的な
何でも自分のものにしようという波で違うんですね
だからそこでいつでもつなぎは役は無知がやるんですね
それ一つ どんな煩悩を持っていたかということで
次の煩悩は変わりますというね
次に この自分がずっとどんなのフリークエンシーって何でしたっけ
言葉はわからない 回数というかね
1 日何回起こるのか  1 日何回欲張るのかとかね
それでなんとなく決められる
その回数ですね その割合
性格っていうのはそんなところで怒り
怒りっぽい人やとかね
なかなか怒らない人やっていうのは
この回数が少ないっていうことなんですね
それは普通生きている上で
それも出来上がっちゃうんですね
もう普通に生きていると
怒る環境ばっかしに生きていると怒りやすくなってしまっているし
怒らない環境でいると欲だけ生まれる性格になったりして
それで何か慣れてしまうというね
だからどんな煩悩に慣れているのかということによって
新しい情報入るとどんな煩悩が生まれるかっていうことは
怒りの煩悩に慣れてる人なら
怒りが生まれる情報だったら
最も簡単に怒りを作ったりする
怒りの情報に慣れてる人の人は欲が出る環境にいると
もうちょっと時間かかったり
ちょっと頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
だから なかなか笑わない人と笑わせるのは大変難しいんだからね
いつでも笑ってる人にも真面目な話してるのに笑ってるんだから
もうこれ真面目な話だ
これそうです 真面目な話をしたら真剣にそれ入れ替えは時間かかるんですね
はい そういうことでも煩悩の
差がつきます はい それに似ていて
この潜在煩悩というものもありますね
潜在煩悩というのは過去になる煩悩なんですね
過去になったデータでもう貪瞋痴のどちらか
強いか弱いかということになってしまうんですね
それで私は貪瞋痴だけと言っても
この潜在煩悩は無勢というし
普通の煩悩は現実に汚れる煩悩は綺麗というし
流れの機能から見るとアサローというんですね
煩悩なんですけど この機能によって言葉を変えているし
項目もそれなりにも変えたりはするんですね
アサと言えば カーマアサはバアサはディッターアサはアヴィッダアサというんですね
怒りが入ってないんですね
アヴィッダアサったっけ
やっぱり四つ四つだと思いますね
チャッタルアサとか言って
書いてますからね カーマは欲
ババは生きていきたいという存在欲ですね
カーマディッターディッターサワというのは邪見が
それ幻覚が本物やと思って
で アヴィッジャーサワっていうのは無明ですね
はい ヤッサアサパリッケーナ
アサはなくなってます
だから阿羅漢になった人は普通に見たり聞いたりしていますけど
その人の心の中は違います
何も漏れません 心の中に何も漏れません
欲も怒りも無知も漏れません
カーマアソディッタアソといえば
もうカーマという欲はディッタっていうのはいろいろ結論に達したりとかね
ああそうだそうだ これはあれだ
これはあれだとかね そういう風に見解は出からないんですね
生きていてよかった なんて幸福でしょうかとか
それはないんです 普通はただ見ている
聞いているだけ 感じている
味わっているだけなんですけど
生きていてよかったねとかね
よくわかりませんだけど
何がよかったんですかと
それがバワーサワなんですね
生きていてよかったよ
何かいいことあった時でしょ
ということは 今まで全然なかったっていうことですからね
でないとあれほど感情的になりませんでしょ
毎日の同じことだったらね
逆を言うんですね つまらないんだと
だから神を信じている人々も
もう私は絶対信じてますよと
私は経験したことありますよと
よく聞いたらもう紙一枚で命拾いしただけの経験なんです
私は真面目に だからあまりにも信じがたいんだからね
真面目に真剣に絶対私は信じてますったら
どういう証拠でしょうかと言っちゃうと
誰々と言うんですね 胸を張って
よく聞くと もうこの連中死にかけちゃって
紙一枚で命を助かっただけの話なんですね
だからその人こうこう
私がこうこうわからないでしょうに
一度もそういう危険な目に遭ったことがないんだから
一回新幹線で閉じ込まれただけ
台風で何か線路に何か屋根が落ちちゃって
それもそんなに大変なことあったとは言えないんだけど
1時間くらい待ってて動きそうもないんだから見てみれば当然動かない
それで知ってる人の家に行って
夜ものすごい贅沢に寝て
朝も朝もすごいごちそうを食べて
新大阪までまた車で乗せてもらったんですから
よくわからないんで あれでその日で帰らなかっただけで
帰ったとしても来て自分の部屋で寝るだけで
そうすると朝ごはんもパン 1枚で終わっちゃう
で 豪華なお風呂もないし
だから だから神を信仰する人ってみんなそういうことなんだよね
だから辛口言いたくなっちゃうんで
やっぱり神を信じなくてよかったね
私はとか そんな不幸な目に遭うぐらいもう不幸なやつなんて
そういう風にいろいろケンカで作ることもよく人間やりますから
常に我々はケンカ作るんですね
ずっといろいろ で そういうのは悟った人にはないんですね
次はアーハレーチャ・アニッシと
まあこれは食事に対してずいぶん執着しないというね
意味なんですね 何食べようかとかね
どのように食べようかとかね
どんな料理方法がよろしいか
もう炭で焼くか油で揚げるかとかね
あれやこれやとか そういうのは何もないんですね
食べるものに対しては執着はしない
期待しない こうなってほしい
ああなってほしいとかね
そんな程度でしょうかとかね
それだったら私たちも何か食べればいいんじゃないかって
その程度で思ってますよとかね
言う人もいますけどね
もう私なんか食べ物は全然もう何かちょこっと食べて
おにぎり 1個でもあふれる余分とかね
そういう食べ物に無関心な人っていうのはいくらでもいますけどね
どうしますかね 悟ってますかね
よくよく見ると七面倒くさいとかで
これだと思いますけど
怠けですね それが 料理作ると思う
また後片付け大変だからもういいや
チンして食べるぞとかね
まあそんな程度のことで
この資格にはなりません
生きることは苦であるだから食べるっていうことは苦を続けることでしょ
どのように苦しめばよろしいかと考える
だからそこがポイントなんです
どのように苦しめばよろしいかとか
だから私たちはこの食べ物は体にいいんだとかね
日本ではどこでも食っちゃうでヘルシーヘルシーでしたっけ？ヘルシーと書いてあればそれで十分です
人間は極限に病気に陥っているかどうかもよくわかりませんだけど
見る限りみんな元気なんですけど
もうもうもう 何でもこれでヘルシー
これでヘルシーとかね
店に行っても絶対知らない葉っぱやら木の実やら根っこやら粉にして
なんだらかんだらとかね
売っていること もうものすごい量
だから面白いものだから取って
これ飲んだらどうなる？何か成分見たら何もないんですね
もう血糖下がるためにはいいと思われている
肝臓の働きを良くすると思われている
と見事に法律に当たらないように書いてます
だから長生きしたいっていうことも
苦しみを伸ばしたいっていうことでしょうね
だから食事っていえばね
種類ありますけどね 仏教ではね
精神的な欲求と物質的な食べ物って
この場合 おそらく食べ物っていうのは食べ物だと思いますけど
だから美味しく食べなくちゃっていうことは出てこないんです
阿羅漢になった人には
だからどんな心か それでわからないでしょう
だからこれ全部否定形で説明してるんです
悟ったんだからってご飯食べますよ
どんな気持ちで食べてるか
それは理解できるものじゃないんです
食べる食欲そのものが執着から生まれてやって
死にたくないという存在欲から生まれるもう一つの煩悩なんです
食べたいということ 生きていきたいんです
死にたくないんです それはもう存在欲とババタンナーと言うんですね
あるいはババウィバワーサ
だから食べたいんですけど
ではできますかね だから阿羅漢になった人もご飯食べますけど
それは肉体がいろんな部品が体からすーっと出ているんですね
固定してないんですね
体は 体のエネルギーは
物質はずっと流れて出ていっているんですね
だから体機能するためには
もう部品がなくなってしまいますね
ただ その出ていってる部品のために新しい物質をちょっと入れて
機械はなんとなく動くようにしてあげるだけ
人間できますが それ感じることさえもできないんです
人間の食欲は煩悩なんです
人間は体みるみるうちにいろんな物質が減っていって
何なのか 機能が衰えているったって
そこは感じませんね お腹が空いた
食べ食べましょうってそれで終わっちゃうんです
あるいは時計見てあ ご飯だとかね
時計見てご飯食べる気になるのはどういうことかと
まあですから このそれさえも我々には理解できないと思います
この食べ物に期待ないと
うん 俗世間の理解能力とは違います
俗世間でもアメリカにそんなに断って断ってない人っていうのはいくらでもいることはいます
はい スギアルのソニアとアニミットは耳目口やさごうちろう
で それはこの前の芸で説明しました
すんげたっていうのは苦ということで
アニメたっていうのはまあ
無双でしたっけね 特色何もないというね
それは涅槃の説明なんですね
涅槃は現象の世界から見れば苦と言わなくちゃいけないんですね
ニミッタっていうのは何かあるあるんだというために
その特色をとってるんですね
これはビルだよというために
我々は他の現象とは違うところをとって
これがビルですと これがゴータミ聖者ですでしたっけ？ですと
で 他と比較して こちらの特徴ような特色何なのかで認識するんですね
人間二人見たらどうしても二人っていうことは分かりますし
じゃあもう一卵性双生児二人だったらどちらどちらかと
二人っていうことだけわかりますけど
どちらどちらかとわからなくなっちゃうんですね
その時 私たちにはその特色がわからないんですね
産んだ親も騙すことはね
一卵性双生児には難なくできるんだからね
いくらか自分で物事をわかるようになって
親からかいたくなったもんですね
なったらして親をからかったりする
我が腹が立つんですね
騙された  そのようにこの現象にはいつでも特色があるんです
これは仏教ではニミッタっていう風に書きますけどもね
それで認識が生まれるんです
これってもう大変ですからね
ただ バラの花 1本見ても
我々花びら一つ一つ見えるし
わかるし だからそれぞれ全部それぞれ特色あるんですから
どちらのの方がね 区別するのかよくわからないでしょうね
とにかく微妙な差も知ってはいるんです
例えばバラの花 バラの花から花びら 1枚取る
で取ってあげたら 見た人が初めて見るバラの花です
これ花びら 1枚ないんだ
わかるでしょ だからそれぞれもうどんなものも特色持っているというふうに
そこでアビダンマでは説明するようになっているんですね
で 特色がなくなると認識する方法っていうのはなかなかないんですね
だからもう海の遠く遠く行って
太平洋の太平洋のど真ん中にいるとかね
何も機械も何も持ってないんだったらどうやってわかるんですかね
で 太陽が見えてもようわからん
どちらが西でどちらが東かっていうね
沈むまで待っていないと
だからそれ特色なんですね
だからコンパス持っていて
あれ特色なんですね 海の真ん中にいて
北どこですかとコンパス見たら北こちらだよと堂々と言えますけど
でなきゃ言えません 特色が必要なんです
それで空間というのはね
一つ人間にはまあ特色がないものだと思いますけど
我々は空間を認識しますけど
それは空間でないものからあのバウンダリーを作るんですね
この部屋の空間といって壁でバウンダリーを作って
そこ特色ありますからね
で こちらは空間であると
本当は認識できないんです
空間は 引き算しているだけ
壁から もし宇宙の もう太陽系とかなんだかかなり遠いところで
何もないところで自分放り込まれたら
宇宙に行った時点で上下消えちゃうでしょ
上下消えたってことはほろっぽも消えるでしょ
だからもう無限の空間の中で
じゃあ場所こちらではなくてあちらだよとどうやって言えますかね
で 人間に宇宙はやっぱり経験あれできないんですけど
仏教の哲学者たちがね
これかなり推測してね
まあ空間はね 特色がないんだと
で 言って あの カテゴリーしてますけど
それはテーラワーダ仏教は認めません
地水火風空にしていますね
仏教は それで空はこの
まあこんな専門的なこと入りませんですけどね
テーラワーダ仏教で涅槃だけ特色のないものにしていますけど
セッサン・セーブではこの空間も同じだと言ってるんですね
まあそれはまあ論理的に考えてるだけで
まあ現実的な人間というのは
まあちょっと推測ですからね
あれは はい  そこ難しい話を置いておいて
我々知っている物質世界
たとえ空間であろうとも
それぞれ特色を持っていて認識するんです
で 涅槃という境地には特色ないんです
だから特色あれば認識できる心は特色ないことを認識するんです
これはもう考えることはできることじゃないんです
だから特色行って来ると言っても特色がないんです
我々には涅槃を理解するためには
もう壁と柱は違うということを知っているような感じで
この違うところ特色だけ言っても欲しいんですが
ないならばもうないと言うしかないんです
はい この涅槃というのはこの特色のない境地
だからそちらには認識もありません
まあそうやって涅槃に達して達しているんだと
その方々の行方はね どうなっているのか
どんな思考でいるのか
死後どうなるのかとかね
あれこれやと探すことっていうのは何もできませんよと
どんな気持ちでいるのかどうかね
調べて無駄だよと あの空に鳥の足跡がないように
鳥は空を飛んでますけど
で 空見てあこちらここからなんだか白鳥飛んでますというと
足跡を見ては言えることできないんです
はい はい まあ一応テキストにストーリーありますけど
そのストーリーはどうやって偈に繋げるかということは私にはよくわかりません
ストーリーと因縁物語とお釈迦様の言葉は合わないんですから
まあそれ置いておきます
で もう一つ今日説明します
はい
読み上げます ヤッシンリアニサマタンガターニアッサーヤターサーリチナスダンターパヒーナマナッサーアナーサヴァッサーデーヴァーピタッサーピハヤンティターディ
ーノ
ヤッシンリアニサマタンガターニアッサーヤターサーリチナスダンターパヒーナマナッサーアナーサヴァッサーデーヴァーピタッサーピハヤンティターディーノ
またアラカンはどんなものかと
また別な偈で説明しています
インドリヤーニサマタンガターニ
インドリヤっていうのは眼耳鼻舌身意ですね
六根 これで命になり なりまして生きているということになるんです
眼耳鼻舌身なければ生き物じゃないでしょうに
だから生き物っていうのは
誰にでも眼耳鼻舌身意は付いてるんです
まあたまたま生命に目がなかったり
耳がなかったりもありますけど
胃はありますね 誰にでも
生命に虫たちとかね いろいろ六根も揃ってない場合はありますけど
大体は体がありますからね
そこあるし 意識 胃はありますからね
とにかく眼耳鼻舌身意あります
それは六つに六根と言いますね
インドリヤと言うんです
サマタンガターね それはしっかりと訓練して制御して調教してもう完了しているんです
サマタンガタっていうのは
まあ制御し終えているんです
はい それで前の偈も同じことを言葉変えてるだけ
眼耳鼻舌身の調教終わってるんだと
もう完了だと もう卒業だと
言ったらもうあの どのように認識すればいいかっていう
もうシステムできてることでしょ？どのように見れば
どのように聞けば どのように味わえばよろしいかと
普通はもう漏れますからね
貪瞋痴が あらゆる煩悩が漏れますからね
もう漏れませんね もう訓練は訓練済み
だから前の偈で まあ認識の中でこういうことを
燃える煩悩がない状態と言っていて
今度はまた別な言葉で六根をちゃんと制御して完了しているんだと
だからまあ自動的に自転車に乗るようになったら別にもう乗れるという感じなんですね
能力はもうついたんですね
それはまたなくなるわけじゃないんです
だから ものを見ても 音を聞いても
味わっても 嗅いでも 心の中で貪瞋痴は生まれません
ですから 例えもそれで変わっていて
アッサヤタサーラティナスーダンタ
サーラティっていうのは馬の調教師でもあるし
まあ馬の運転士でもありますけどね
馬車 の 馬をね 調教するすごい上手な人は馬をしっかりと野生の馬をね
言う通りに仕事をするようにとさっさと調教する
まあそれからそんな暴れ馬ではないんですね
まあ馬に乗れるし 走れるし
それぞれ仕事をさせることはできます
いとも簡単に 馬といえばね 2
種類ありますからね 人間の中で人間育てる馬が子馬を産んで
そこでちっちゃい時から人間と一緒に生活してるんだからね
それから体が大きくなると
ちょこちょこちょこちょこと訓練してあげる方法もありますし
ただ馬はもう放し飼いにしておいて
馬が必要になったら まあいい若い馬を捕まえて引っ張ってくるんですね
それから調教させると
両方の方法はあるんですね
で そんなに仕事にも役に立たない馬たちとかね
みんな放してあげる それで野生でみんな餌を食べて
水を飲んで 子供を育てて
子供すくすくと自然の中で育っていくと
人間が馬の用ができたら
じゃあ 3頭取りましょうと言って選んで
あの子とこの子とこのいいやと
で取って連れてきて 野生でしょうに
でも調教するんです しっかりと
かなり早く もうしっかりした馬に仕事をできる馬になってしまいますね
まあそんなもんで 馬とゾウはね
野生のものを取っても調教することはできます
で 他の動物はそれほど簡単ではないんです
この例えで馬を使っているのは
この馬馬の種類ですね
馬っていうのはいろんな種類があって
それなりに性格があって
どこまで調教できるかっていうことは大体は決まってるんですね
で 荷物運ぶ馬は走る馬には全然使えない
戦いに使う馬はもう荷物運んだりすることにはできない
で 走るだけのただ競馬とかね
走るだけにある馬もいるし
ただ走るだけ ちょっと背中の重さがちょっと変わっただけでもスピードは変わったりもする
走る馬には荷物運ぶことは全く無理
そんな力がないんです
骨には 荷物運ぶ馬には走れません
人間はもっと走れます
しかし どんな荷物でも車に入れてあげれば
まあ引っ張りますけどもね
牛は力あります で 戦争で軍隊として使う馬がまた違いますね
体力が結構ありますし
それなりに走れるし で
そういうわけで馬のいろいろ種類がありますから
この中でやっぱり最高の馬っては何なのかと
まあいろいろ人間が妄想するでしょう
そこでこの駿馬とか何とか言ってる馬がね
一番最高やと思っていて
王がそのような馬を見つけたら
それは王の個人的な乗り物になるんですね
なんでかというと その馬は言わなくてもやってくれる
だからこのプライドが高い
鞭で打たれるよりは死んだ方がマシやと
だから人間どうしても強いんだから馬をこき使ってるし
それはなかなか動物にとってはもう避けられない
しかし プライドはすごく高い
こいつらに鞭で打たれてたまるかと
それだったら死んだ方がマシやと思ったって自分で死ぬこともできないんですね
動物たちに それで馬が取る態度は
人間が何考えてるのかと
どんな気持ちでいるのかと
これをしっかりと察知して
それに合わせて仕事をする
ちょっと早く行かなくちゃとか思った途端
馬がガタンガタンガタンガタン走っちゃうと
あ ここなんか気持ちいいところだなとか
のんびり回ってみたいなって気持ちが生まれると
馬が普通のギャロップやめて
もうゆっくりとトチンということになるんです
だから乗る人はもうただもう乗っていればいいんです
で 馬に乗って旅に出て
本人がなんか眠くなってきたならば
これ馬はよく知っているんですね
そうすると丁寧に行くと
そこはまあ この駿馬という馬なんですね
すごいスピードもあります
しかし逆に それほど高貴な立派な人間でなければ乗せてあげない
乗ったらきなり暴れて
もう足を上げて倒す 落とす
背中には乗せません だらしない人間を
すごい高貴な 立派な もう馬のプロか
もうその馬を調教してる戦士たちか
もう王様とかね そういう人乗ったら
自分の仕事しなさいと
その馬の 例えば戦士だったら
あんたはもう馬軍隊だからね
もう だったらもう司令官で馬に乗って自分の仕事しなさいと
そういう態度 馬は全部環境を把握して
走るべきか 止まるべきか
飛ぶべきかとか そこは自分で計算してやってるんです
だから馬に隠れて馬のおかげで逃げていただこうとか何とかいう腰抜けの戦士は乗れません
そういう馬っていうのはインド人が想像しているんですね
実際いるかどうかはよくわかりませんだけど
大体馬っていうのはね
人間の心を読んでますからね
そんなに そんなに不思議なことでもないんです
だから言いたいのは動物をバカにしてはいけないんですよ
動物はものすごい物事を知ってますからね
喋れないんだからっていい加減バカにしちゃってもね
もうこうかなりもう知ってます
まあどちらにしても 馬を調教した馬のように
何の問題もなく六根を調教して完了している
あまりこのたとえはもうそんなに関係ないんですけど
六根を完了しているんだというね
どのように六根の制御完了制御完了しているのかというと
この老煩悩がもう二度と生まれないようにプログラムをしっかり育てて
ありのままに如実に見られるように
もうシステムを作っているんです
パヒーナマナスマナマンがないんだよと
マンがないということは自我がないという意味なんですね
我はいるという それがもう幻覚であると知っているんです
如実に見ると我はなくなっちゃうんですね
我っていうのは妄想概念でいらないんです
私がいるんだということは後からもう生える虚妄想概念なんです
私がいるんだという気持ちがなくても生きているんです
だからそこあるところでお釈迦様がね
もう このある邪教の人がね
間違った言葉間違ってね
お釈迦さんも 私も同じこと自我が無くせと言ってるではないかと
違いますよと お釈迦様は答えるんですね
そんなことだったら赤ちゃんがね
生まれつき悟ってますよと
こんな自分という気持ち
自我のところが自分という気持ちすらないんだよと
あんたの教え正しければ
もう赤ちゃんはあなた方の宗教と見れば
もう完全にもうそれで悟ってますよと
違うんじゃないかと で
言葉同じであっても微妙なところがありますのでね
しかし 潜在的な問題あるんだと
赤ちゃんにそれから生まれてくるんだと
だから修行でそこをもうその問題ですよ
解決するの わざわざ自我をなくすということじゃないんです
自我という幻覚ですね
だからこの 自我あるわけじゃないんだからなくせないでしょうね
ないものはどうやってなくすんですかね
自我がないというんだからないんです
じゃあそれをなくしましょうと
なくすために持ってこいと言わなくちゃね
はい 持ってきてください
これからなくしますよと
燃やし燃やしますよと
で ないんだから だからないものはあると思う誤解を正すだけなんです
だから赤ちゃんはその誤解を正すことはしていないんだから
それから自我が生まれてくるんです
自我の錯覚が それで自分がいるんだぞという錯覚がないならば
慢は生まれないでしょう
慢というのは自我の錯覚の仕事のことなんです
何かに錯覚に陥ったら
その錯覚でやることはすべて慢なんです
そんなに難しくはないんです
自分がいるんだということで
もう自分と他人いるでしょうに
それでいろいろ比較するんです
だから人と喋っても慢が割り込んできて
この人喋り方下手だなと
時点で私はしっかり喋ってるんだっていう意味ですよ
この人の話し方見事ですね
感動しますねと言っちゃうと
自分が下手やってことでしょう
両方慢なんです 一つは一は卑下慢で
二は あ いえ二は卑下慢で
前はもう高慢で 私の方がこの人の話し方うまくないねと言っちゃうと
自分の方がうまいと思ってるんだから高慢で
まあどうしてもこの世間で生きる場合はね
物を判断しなくちゃあかんだからね
良し悪し あれやこれやとかね
そのリンゴを買う場合は
どんなリンゴを買うのかと
リンゴのところから自分が四個選ぶ場合はね
やっぱりいろいろ判断するでしょ
そのそれを判断と また自分中心にしてする判断というのはまたあるんですね
なんのことなく 自分と関係なくリンゴを買わなくちゃいけない
で これでもう山積みにしていて
まあ 四個二百円で売ってますよと言って
で 安売りすると一個買えますからね
じゃあ四個もう百三十円やと
で だから四個自分で選ばなくちゃいけないでしょうね
そこでまあどんな基準で選ぶのかという
それも判断ですけどね
色で選ぶ場合もあるし
大きさで選ぶ人もいるし
私は香りで選ぶし 中のところのどんな香りかと
あの種とか周りはね 外じゃなくてその香りが出てくるんです
で 美味しいリンゴは一番真ん中のところは生きてるんです
だからそれぞれのまあ判断の仕方なんですけどね
しかし ある人は私が小さいリンゴの方が食べやすいとかね
私が大きいリンゴが欲しいやとか
選ぶ場合は私が張り込んでるんですね
その時は慢が働いてるんです
私の好みではといえば
この慢が入っていて 私が知ってる知識能力から見れば
このリンゴがいいんだよというと
自我ではないかもしれません
リンゴのことをよく知っている人で
それだったらリンゴの良し悪し決める基準から見れば
このリンゴの方がいいだよと
しかし 私はリンゴ嫌いだよという場合もありますね
そのリンゴの知識人があんたリンゴを買りたいの？知らない
じゃあこれとこれはもう間違いなし
選んでくださいと あんたよくリンゴのこと知ってますからね
よく美味しいリンゴ食べていらっしゃる
私はリンゴ嫌いですよと
いうケースもあります
[笑い]だから私が理由嫌いですと言ったら
どんな理由で嫌いかわかりませんだけど
自我入ってるかもしれませんし
入ってないかもしれませんし
判断する場合は この私が張り込む割り込むところがもう慢の煩悩が機能しています
だから私があの人をあんまり好きじゃない
気に入らないとかいう場合は慢なんですね
あの環境は私には合いませんとかね
とにかく判断基準に自分という基準が判断使うんですね
判断する場合は 基準に自分がなるたびに慢の煩悩が働いています
だから相当ありますよ
日常生活の中で で 印刷したい
これからプリントアウトしたいんですけど
あの あの 品質のいい紙を
持ってくださいと言ったら
いろんな安い紙もあったりして
その中からそれだったらこの紙でしょうと選ぶ場合は
自分ということは割り込んでないんですね
で Wordで文章を作って
じゃあ印刷してよしあし見ましょうという場合は
まあただメモとしてですからと言ったら
あ そうですか ではこちらで裏で印刷しましょうとかね
使った紙を で ああ これ
まあここは じゃあはい
出てきました じゃあ最終的なプリントアウトします
じゃあいい紙で それだったらこの紙でどうとかね
それの場合も我々は判断していますね
その時私の好みはこの紙だよではないんです
ですから 例えば公のところに送る手紙なんですけど
文章なんですけど やっぱり本人が私はこの花模様ある紙がさり好きですよとかね
ピンク色で花模様で こちらでプリントアウトしますと
ただそれ勝手な判断で
自我で それでだからといって別に特別に公の人々はね
もう花模様の紙に印刷したんだから
これに特別扱いしましょうとかはないし
そのようにこのいろんなものについて我々は判断していきますが
慢が絡んだり絡まなかったり
電車やら車やら飛行機やら操縦する人々もずっと判断しっぱなしですけど
慢が入ってる じゃあ困るでしょう
だからうまく上手に無事に操縦するのかというところで微妙な判断しながらやってますね
そこは慢が入ってやることもできますが
まあ必ず に会うっていうことも
その危険性もあります
必ずんでもなくてもね
かっこつけて運転するとかね
あの自動車レースなんかの場合でも
やっぱり慢が入っちゃうと
私は負けん 負けます そういう人々にとかね
本当に勝ってやろうと思って慢が割り込んじゃって負けます
自動車 自動車レースというのは
いかに落ち着いて機械を操縦するのかと
いかに瞬間に判断するのかと
そういう技術的なことでやると思ったら
自我がなくなるでしょうね
うまくいくんですね あの人に勝たなくちゃと思った時点でもうダメになったりする
だから この世の中で判断する作業っていうのは
もう全部判断する作業ですけど
生きることはね そこで自分が入るたびに慢が入ってくるんです
そのたびに失敗するんです
いろんな悩み 苦しみが後からついてくるんです
専門的な客観的な判断の場合は
別に判断正しかった 間違ったかと
そんな程度でそれほど大きいことになりません
慢って 慢っていうのはそういうことで測る
測ることですけど 測って判断してはいけないではなくて
自分という気持ちを割り込む場合なんですね
良くない それが初めから間違いなんです
自分という自我がないんです
だから錯覚で判断する
ということで 慢がする判断はすべてダメな判断なんです
慢に基づいて正しい判断できません
そういうわけで 私があの人を嫌いということ判断はもうその時点で間違いなの
私がですからね 自分が入らない判断の場合は
いくらか合っていることがあるんです
ですが この世の中で慢以外判断基準何も使わない人もいるんですからね
相当迷惑な存在なんです
それで阿羅漢になった人にはパヒーナ・マーナ
マーナがもうない それからアナサヴァッサ
煩悩はない 四行目はただ終了するための一行でデーヴァピタッサピヘヤンティターディノ
ターディノっていうのは
そういう風にアンノンニャー境地にアンリッサの境地に立っていると
人には神々さえも好かれますよと
仏教の世界ではね 神はいませんだけど
神々はいるんだからね
多数派複数のね 一神教じゃないんだからね
まあそれは仏教はね 批判する値することにも値しない馬鹿げた話としてもう捨ててますからね
思考は その代わりに生命としては神々でいるんですけど
もう立場がね 人間よりは幸福で優れたというか
レベル高いんですね 人間も神の世界には行きたがったりもするし
しかし 仏教の世界では神々の立場が下がってますね
仏道歩む人々のことは神々のより上だというふうにしているんですね
だから阿羅漢になった人は
神々にも恨まれる 神々に敬われる
好まれる 好かれる存在なんです
だからストーリーはね
何かちょっとご自分で勉強してください
で 他にもう芸と合うストーリーが見つけたら説明します
こちらにあるのがマハーカッチャーナという阿羅漢大長老がね
かなり地方に住んでいたんです
アヴァンテでしたっけ
アヴァンテって で 遠くからそれでもお釈迦様の説法なんかある時はまあまあ大きな説法会ある場合は参加する
で それで遠く来るんだから参加するんだっていうことを他の阿羅漢たち言っていて
みんな座る 座ってるんですね
それでまあマハカッチャーナ長老がまだ来ていないんですね
しかし 年順番で座りますから
マハカッチャーナ長老
マハカッチャーナ長老に座れる場所は置いておいて
もう阿羅漢たちは座ってるんで
そちらにも神々も説法しようと来ていたみたいし
で 帝釈天はもう来ていて
阿羅漢たちはよく知っているし
誰が誰来ているのかとかね
で 帝釈天があっち見たりこっち見たりしているんだと
それはもうそれからマハカッチャーナ尊者がお坊さんたちのところに入って
自分を座る場所を空いてありましたからね
すると突然帝釈天がびっくりしちゃって
待ってました 待ってましたと
マハカッチャーナ尊者がもう急ぐの急ぐのずっと待って待ったというマハカッチャーナ尊者ところにサッサと行って
足を両足を自分の手で取って
一生懸命足を触ったりして礼をするんですね
でお坊さんたち 帝釈天もいろいろ好みがあるやつやなと
阿羅漢 阿羅漢たち誰でも平等なんですけど
丁寧に礼をすればいいのに
もうマハカッチャーナ
マハカッチャーナ尊者のファンなんですね
だからもうずっと待っていたんです
来るまで だからなんかエピソードは関係ないんですけど
なんかまあ普通の人間と同じくね
自分が好きなタレントさんがいますよと
タレントさんみんな大体能力は同じくありますけど
自分が好きな歌手がいるんだとかね
他の人はダメかっていうとそういうわけじゃないんだけどね
どうしようもないんですね
本人がその人のことを好きだからね
そういったようで マハカッチャーナ尊者のような方々は
もうやっぱり神々もそういう風にファンになりますよという話に無理にしています
あまり話の内容とお釈迦様の教えの内容とストーリーはそれほど関係ないんです
えーと これはもう少しもう二つでも十分やと思いますけど
はい この偈でやっぱり説明しているのは
この六根 眼耳鼻舌身のファンクション機能をしっかり正しく認識できるように訓練終了しているんだというところと
それで自我が現れないんだからね
認識が間違うんだから
自我という錯覚が生まれるんだから
それで繋げて自我がない
それなら煩悩は生まれるはずもない
じゃああと一文ありますけど
あの九十五番目 パタウィサモーノーウィルッジャティ
インダキールーパモーターディスッバトー
ラハドーアペータカッダモー
サンサーラナバヴァンテターディーノー
パタウィサモーノーウィルッジャティ
インダキールーパモーターディスッバトー
ラハドーアペータカッダモー
サンサーラナバヴァンテターディーノー
で パタウィサモーっていうのは大地のように
ウィルッジャティっていうのは
まあ立ち上がることはないんだと
腹が立って攻撃するとかね
それ心の状況 阿羅漢の心は大地のようであると
穴を掘ろうが 地下爆弾を実験しようか
汚れやあれやこれや入れようが
花を咲こうが 大地はね
別に腹が立って攻撃することはないんです
逆に ああ 花が作ってくれましたね
大地の上で よかったよかった
それもないんです ということは
情報に対して左右されないんですね
眼耳鼻舌身から入る情報は触れる
だけど 大地のような心を持っている
インダキールーパモーターディスッバトー
だから心は動揺しないでしょう
大地ですからね それでしっかり安定しているんですね
このしっかり安定していることは
仏教ではだいたいインダキーラという
なんとか柱なんですね
よくわかりません で もう全くも倒れない
しっかりした柱って意味なんですね
だから大黒柱ですね で
日本でも建築に応じてこの
あの 柱を植えるんですね
あの 何といいますか 何
あれ 何と言いますか あの
塔 塔 あの  五重の塔  五重の塔とかね
で 五重の塔なんか作る場合は
真ん中ずっと柱一本  心柱
あ 心柱 ずっとあって そこを周りに木を組み立てていくんですね
柱と周りのビルはほとんど関係ないんです
しかし 心柱のおかげで地震が起きても
もう五重の塔だけは倒れません
心柱につけて 心柱のおかげで屋根を支えてもらうということもしてないんです
しかし 心柱一本でしっかりないとまたダメなんです
で それでもそんな長生きはないんですからね
まあつなげてますけど
で そのようにこの全部支えてくれて
自分が安定しているんですね
だから阿羅漢はなんか心柱のような存在という
この安定感を 心の安定感をそうやって説明しているんです
認識はするわ 見えるものは見えるわ
聞こえるものは全部聞こえるわ
なのに心がしっかりと大地のように安定している
で そこをまた心柱にたとえているんです
インド建築ではどんな風になっているかということは
まあ私はあまりよくわかりませんね
仏典ではね 街を作る時とか
お城を作る時とか 最初にこのインダキーラをつけておくんだと
それがもう四方からどんな風が吹いてきても揺らぎませんと
[笑い]おそらく五重塔のやり方
思考とパターンと同じことかもしれませんね
わかりませんね 阿修羅様がインダ18柱を石柱をね
作って作って歩き回ってましたけどね
あれはただの柱そのままばっかりですけど
あれ壊れて壊れて今1本しか壊れてないものはないんです
それも土の中に埋めて埋められてあってね
今仏頭とか壊れて上土が一番トップのところだけ見えていて
そこでずっと発掘すると
柱が全部もう完全な形で残っていたんですけど
それがインダキーラかどうかもう分かりませんし
それだったらただのおしゃれだけで
建物のどこかにでっかい柱がある
かなりおっかないと思いますけど
阿羅漢の心はしっかりとそういう柱のようにしっかりしているんですね
ターディ それは安定している
スッバトーっていうのは自分の修行を完成しているんだっていうことですね
それから 3行目 ラハドーアペータカッドも泥のない湖のようだと心は
心はとても澄んでいます
で ドロドロの水の湖じゃなくて
そこに泥がないんです
そうすると水がすごく綺麗に通して見えるんですね
下まで 泥のない湖のような心であると
それからサンサーラ・ナ・ブワンティ・ターディノ
そういうターディという言葉が 2回入ってますけど
サンサーラ 輪廻転生することはないんだと
それでまた阿羅漢ってどんなものかと聞けば
心は大地のようなものであると
精神的にはもう心柱のようにしっかり安定しているんだと
また 泥のない湖のように水がすごく澄んでいる
心はそのようなものであると
輪廻転生しないと はい
わかりますかね お釈迦様一生懸命説明してやりますけど
これ否定形で説明しても
あ なるほどわかりましたってことにはいかないんです
ですから 涅槃解脱 それから聖者というのはね
人間には計り知れない状況
境地にいるんですからね
それでもやっぱりお釈迦様は親切にも説明してあげようとは努力はしています
はい この程度でまあ終了したいと思います
では 質問の時間です  何か質問ありますか？ えーと
仏教を実践する際に何を原動力にすればいいのかっていう部分について教えていただきたいんですが
例えばその もしかしたら世の中には
世の中には苦しいことがいくらかあるのかもしれないって気づき始めてる人がいるとして
それでその それからそのフラフラした状態から
この仏教は本当のことを言ってるかもしれないから
ちょっと勉強してみようっていうところに行くまでの
その力に何を使えばいいのかっていうのを
ちょっとそれは難しい問題なんじゃないかと思って
その悟っていない限りは
その正しい目的といっても何かわからないと思うので
その何を目指すように言えばいいのか
そしてそれが修行が進むにつれてどのように変化していくのか
どのように清められていくのか
そういうのをちょっと教えていただきたいんですけど
うーん  例えばその 例えばその自分が未熟だからといって
怒りによってその仏教に自分を縛りつけていたら
全く修行が進まないわけで
そこをどういう風に解決すればいいのかっていうのをちょっと考えたい
うん [咳]正直に言うとね
まあ私たちにとってはね
そういう風な思考する人の心境っていうのは見えてくるんだからね
で こういうのは助けてあげることはできませんよという答えしか出せませんだけどね
で この優柔不断でフラフラして生きていて
まあなんとかすればいいんじゃない？では何すればいいかな
じゃあ仏教でも ということですから
最初からもう優柔不断で物事を判断できる能力がない
人間としてしっかりしてないっていうところは見えてくるんですね
人間としてしっかりしてない場合は
もう何やってもダメっていうことにもなっちゃうんですね
だから いくらが苦しいかもしれませんっていうことを勉強してないし
勉強したくもないし まあもしかすると言ってるんだからそうかもしれませんとかね
それはもう仕事をやる仕事もない
何も家でやることがないおばあちゃんたちがね
テレビを見ているような感じなんですね
[笑い]もしかするとあの人本当に悪い人じゃない？とかね
自分自身はそのような不安は何もないしね
で 例えば子どもとやって法律でまあ通りましたと
ああ そうですかね ああ
よかったねと 何がよかったんですか？まあよくわからない
[笑い]あれはもう自民党反対してとんでもないことやとか
ああそうですかね それだったらよくないでしょうね
やっぱりとんでもないこと私は大反対
何に大反対する？それはわからない
そこでマスコミにとってはすごいありがたいことにもうインタビューしたら
もう九十パーセント大反対と
このもう右目左目わからない
何十人十人二十人ぐらいに聞いて
そこでパーセント見たら八十パーセントとか
[笑い]だからこの そういうふうな生き方の人々はこの世の中で何も得られないんですね
うーん だったら本当に答えられないんで
どうすればいいかと もうそれだったら
私もわからないね 私の周りにもそういう人ばっかしで
[笑い]もう助けてあげることはできないんですね
ああ そうかいで終わっちゃいますからね
[笑い]だから人間というのは
あの なんか決めないとね
このなんか決める 決められないでしょう
だからといってもね これ性格的なことでね
何か決めちゃえば結構楽々なんですね
育ててあげることはね
親にしても 子供はこれやりたいと決めてしまえば
もうじゃあいいや わかったということで
いろいろね それならもうあの先生の他いいんじゃない
この先生の方がいいんじゃないとかね
じゃあ親も子供連れて外国でも住んだ方がいいんじゃないとかね
音楽やりたいと やっぱりじゃあしょうがない
もう金もないんだけど
なんとかして外国で まあそこまで親献身的にやっちゃいますよ
子供のために日本の家を売っちゃってね
もうイタリアで住んだりとかね
すごい苦労したりして
というのは その場合は子供が道を決めてますからね
で ウィーンにイタリアに行きたいと言っていて
本当にそれで行って私は大丈夫かなとかね
で うまくいかなかったらどうしよう
もうどうしようもないんですね
助けることできないんですね
親はいきなりでは家を売り払って
向こうでなんとかして
もうあなたの側に面倒見たりしますから
ちゃんと面倒見たいと言えないんですね
言って向こうで 1ヶ月間経ったところで
やっぱりお母さんに嫌になっちゃった
もうあまりイタリア語も喋れませんしね
イタリア人のこの派手な性格も私にはちょっと合いません
日本に帰りたいと もう
もう日本に もう全部お金もなくなってるしね
だからこの そういうところなんですから
この曖昧 優柔不断 中途半端というところは
まあなんとかならないと
この柔軟性と違いますよ
優柔不断は まあ知ることによって人はいくらかまあ固めてしっかりしますからね
まあ知ることにするしかないんで
だから子供には勉強しなさいと言ってるでしょうね
もうガチャガチャガチャガチャ言わないでとにかくやりなさいよと
これは役に立つんでしょうかとかね
将来仕事にそんなことを考えてなくてね
どうでもいいんです もうしっかりと教育を受けると
なんとかもう固めてくるでしょう
[背景の雑音]だからこの人は何を学ぶか
仏教を学ぶか 修行するかしないかとかとか
そういうもうやってることよりも
この この心の基本的なね
一番基本的なところの状況なんですね
土台のところね そこは優柔不断だったら
もうどんな建物作っても倒れますね
いいですか  まだ終わってないんで
私は  あ はい  仏教の歴史を見ると
この答えたっても理解しないとは覚悟の上ですけど
やっぱり悟った人々はみんなしっかり者なんですね
あの九百人ぐらい人を殺したアンゴリマーラ長老にしても
殺人鬼ですけど 性格はしっかりしてるんです
優柔不断は微塵もないんです
だから なんか変ですけどね
自分の先生の一番気に入る弟子でしたし
すっごく頭が良くて そこで彼があんまりにも頭が良くて
先生がすごい可愛がってるんだから
他のもう弟子たちが嫉妬して
何かもうからくりやったんだとね
先生と仲が悪くなるようにと
だから先生がもうとんでもないやつよ
こいつは殺さなくちゃと
思ってももう教育者だからね
人を殺すわけにはいけません
だから卒業する時はもう先生に何かプレゼントをあげなく
いわゆる学費を卒業してからあげるんです
そこまで住んで 先生と一緒に生活して勉強はする
修行して卒業する時は結構いくらかはそれなりのね
ものはあげたりする それでアンゴリマーラさんが先生
勉強終わりましたんですけど
この最後の感謝のあれはどうしますか？と
伝統的に決まってますからね
これはもう何かどうしても差し上げなくちゃならないんで
君ならね 別に何もあげなくてもいいんだよと
しかしこれやらなくちゃいけない
しかし一つありますよと
私はある神様に何とか何とかしますと約束しましたけど
で これは君 私の方にやってくれればいいんだと
それぐらいわかったけど
何がと言ったら 神様にこの人を千人もね
生贄にしてあげる 千人だから
この人はこれが先生無理ってことも言えないし
先生が言ったことはしてあげなくちゃいけないし
なんで千人も ちょうど一人二人ぐらいは
そこは反論もしないし
それで考えたのは 学問が終わりました
先生のお礼のあれをお礼をあげなくちゃいけない
これも決まり 先生は私にこういう仕事を与えた
じゃあやりますと しっかりやっちゃったね
人殺し 先生の狙いは 人間は一人二人殺しちゃうと
もうすぐもう終わりだと
でも その計画はもううまくいかなかったんです
人を殺すんだったら 捕まったら話にならんでしょうに
また千人も倒さなくちゃいかんでしょうに
しっかりと千人までやりますと
しっかりやるんです 誰にも捕まることも何もできない
それで最後の人 じゃああと一人やと
これで私はそれ終わりますと
だから計画はあるんだよ
人殺しで生活はしたくないんです
ただ 神様にあげるこの生贄の釘はやらなくちゃいけない
そちらにまた善悪判断はしない
最後の人が誰が来てももう最後だからやりますと思ったところでお釈迦様が入ったんですね
だからお釈迦様の時点もあのしっかりした性格があったんだから
いわゆるやることはやると
決めたことをやるというね
それでお釈迦様とお話やったらね
だからもうなぞなぞの話でしたけどもね
お釈迦様に待てと言ったらね
あのね 私はずっと待ってますよとお釈迦様歩きながら言うんです
私はすでに待ってますけど
走ってるのは君じゃないかと
本人も疲れ果てて止まってるんですね
お釈迦様を追っかけて行って捕まれなかったんだから
あれ 何を言うんですか
この出家はと 自分がすっごい勢いで歩いてるのに
私はもう止まってるのに
歩いてる人は待ってるというし
待ってる私には走ってるというし
これどういう意味でしょうかと
言ったらこういうことやと
説明するでしょうに お前はね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみで生命を殺しながら
どこまで輪廻で走り回ると思うかと
私は一切行為をやめているんだよと
だからこれで輪廻全部完璧に停止していますからと
これすごい教えやと 勉強しなくちゃ
あれもうもう次のことにすぐにかかったんですね
それならそれを勉強しますと
もうあとは後ででもできますから
その勉強終わってるしね
まだ時間制限もなかったんだから
先生 これ 1週間でやってくださいとか
3週間でやってくださいとかなかったんだから大丈夫ですね
結果決めるんです それなら教えてくれと
だから この人もっと出て行く前に勉強してもらわなくて
ピシッと いいよということで
もう教えてあげて それでお釈迦さん連れて行くんですね
だからずいぶん間もないうちに阿羅漢にも達するんですね
だからこの基本的には心の性格の強さっていうかね
みんなそういう人々ばっかりなんです
曖昧で入った人はみんな失敗しましたね
少なかったとかね 何人か還俗もしましたからね
仏教 もしかすると人気もあるし
まあ王様たちやらね みんなやっているし
まあなんかやってみようかと
いう気分で入る人々はもう途中でももうできない
これってすごく難しいんですね
やっぱり ですから我々はまず
この曖昧中途半端な思考はなんとかしなくちゃいけない
善悪判断は後でいいんです
で 今も頭と判断能力がないと何がいいか
何が悪かとわからないしね
やっぱり仕事をする場合でも
やっぱり抜群にうまくいくかどうかやっぱりわからないでしょうに
とにかく自分やるべきことをしっかりやればいいでしょう
その心の強さが私の義務を果たしましたよと
結果 こんなこんなと ですけどとかね
それでいいんです いい結果になるわけもないし
どうかなとかね その精神だったらもう
じゃあとにかくやってみようかなとかね
それではできないんですね
で 溺れたら まあ私はあんまり泳げないんだからしょうがないんだ
そんなことを言っていられる場合じゃないでしょうね
とにかくちょこっと手足踏んだら泳げるようなの見たことあるんだけど
じゃあやってみようかと
だったら必死でやらなくちゃいけない
必死でやると泳げますからね
だからインド文化では
言ったらこの仏教での言葉ではないんですけど
サンスクリット語で書いている諺なんですけどね
人はね あの 将来の結果云々ではなくて
自分のやるべきことはもう完璧にやっておけばいいんじゃないかという言葉があるんですね
何もやらないよりはマシじゃないのかと
うん  そういうことで まあいろいろ気持ちをしっかりまず定めてること
それを定めてくると そこは道が間違っているならば
誰かにこれを道が間違ってますから
こういう風にしてくださいとアドバイスすることができるようになります
で それから最終的な答え出しますね
仏教はやってみようかなとかね
で そうならば仏教はなぜやるのかっていうことをね
なぜ仏教にしたのかとかね
世の中でやることはいっぱいあるんだから
こういうわけで仏教にしましたとかね
いうところをしっかりしなくちゃいけないんです
なんとかして 自分が選択するんだからね
で 何一つわかってない人は
あれもよくこれもあれ
無数に世の中にあることはいいんだけど
まあもしかすると仏教で言うなら苦しいかもしれませんしねとかね
で キリスト教で言うのは天国かもしれません
この世の中はとかね まあどちらでもいいんだけど
じゃあ仏教に出会ったんで
じゃあこれやってみるとかね
何も迷惑ですね だから自分でしっかりするんですね
じゃあ仏教やることに決めたと
それだったら なんでまた私はこんな仏教に決めたのかとかね
そこはちょっとなんかしっかりした方がね
曖昧ないように それから簡単ですね
それから導くのは簡単です
はい 以上です じゃあこちら
どちらでも  えーと 急にちょっとレベルが違うような質問ですが
うちに八歳の子と四歳の子どもがおりまして
テレビゲームが大好きです
それで先ほどの話では
子どもにやりたいことをやらせてあげるという話もありましたし
長老のご本の中にですね
親の仕事は子どもを自由にさせることだということも読ませていただいたんですけども
その子どもがゲームをやりたい
ゲームをやりたいっていう時に
どういう態度で臨むのがいいのかっていうことが
もし何か指針になることを教えていただければと思いまして
よろしくお願いします
それはそんなにね 大きい問題じゃないでしょうね
親の責任というものありますからね
子供は物事わからないでしょうね
だから目の前の面白いことはやりたがっちゃうし
ゲームやりたいことを子供が決めた道じゃないでしょうね
そうやって誤解するとね
[笑い]まだ子供は道は決まってないでしょうね
子供は自分の道を決めるのはもう五
六 十五 六 七 八 二十歳辺りでしょうね
小さい時も自分の道を決めてくれればありがたいんですけど
私は大きくなったら医者になりますとかね
弁護士になりますとか
子供は決めれば それはそれで大変ありがたいことです
けど まだ小さな子供は見た見たまま
じゃあそうなります ああなりますって言うんだから
もうそれをもうそんなに大したことはないし
子供は一人前で物事の判断できるようになってくると
自分で道を決めるならば
親がもうそこは応援するのは簡単でしょうし
小さな子供にも 楽しければいいんじゃんという感じで生きてる人々でしょうね
だから親っていうのはもうすごく苦労して工夫してね
子供はなんとなく正しい方向へね
なんとなく導くことは
まあ親の仕事であって
それで親が成長するんです
親になるんです 子供が生んだんだからと現れたんだから
あって親になったとか
何考えてるんですかね
親も親の勉強ありますから
父親にも父親の まあ自分の奥さんに子供が
じゃあ私は父親ですよ
何かって ただのバカな男でしょうね
ですから これから毎日毎日
父としての一人前にならなくちゃいけないし
お母さんも母としての一人前にならなくちゃいけないんですね
だから 子供はやってることを一つ一つ自分の勉強になるものなんです
自分が親として一人前になるための宿題ばっかし
今も宿題出してます 私たちはゲームやりたい
他はやりたくない はい
あんたはどうするのかと
で 負けてるでしょうね
子供に それでいかに楽しく子供たちに気付かす
そこをコントロールするのかっていうね
それが親の能力なんですね
だからそこら辺はね 子供は私は見てないんだから正確は分かりませんし
どんな風に言えばいいかと
ダメっていうことだけは言ったら言った人がダメなんですね
やるなよと やめなさいと
やめなさいという場合はありますけど
例えば興奮しちゃってガーって言って自己管理できなかったらやめなさいと言った方がいきなりガクンって
そのケース以外はね  喧嘩になっちゃったとかね
お互いもうもう興奮しちゃって
もう何だか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
それはいきなりドーンと声を出してやめなさい
それ以外はもういりませんね
やめろとかね もうそれぞれその子供たちはいろいろポイントを持ってると思いますよ
例えばゲームやってるんだったら
ゲーム楽しいでしょ じゃあお母さんとお父さんと全然遊ばなくていいでしょ
じゃあ可愛がってあげてもよろしいんだから
はい どうぞやってください
私たちは別に楽しくやるぞとかね
もしお母さんが可愛い欲しくて父はと遊びたくてそういう気持ちあるならば
これダメと言って飛んでくるんですね
それだったらちょっと勉強したら
お母とお父さんは大好きになりますけどとかね
勉強しない ゲームばっかしやっちゃうと
なんかちょこちょこちょこ
いやにいやになって すぐ嫌いな人になるかもしれませんよとかね
プレゼントあげたくなったりして
どこか連れて行きたくなったりしてとかね
そういう風にその子供の性格を見たら
そこら辺でなんとなくもう嫌だとダメではなくてね
一人一人の子供っていうのは
それぞれ自分だけ特有な性格を持ってるんですね
こちらにたまたま来る木下さんのね
長男がもうすごい可愛いんですね
ちっちゃい時は可愛いというとすごい気分が悪いんです
その子はね かっこいいと言わなくちゃいけないんです
本人の世界の中で可愛いというのは
もうなんか気持ち悪い
もしかすると可愛いと言ったら女の子と勘違いした可能性もあるかもしれませんし
かっこいいとかっこいいという感じ
だからみんなもう必ずもうかっこいいと子供に言わなくちゃいけない
だからそれではっきり性格わかるでしょ
で 子供もちょっと弱いカードを持ってるんですね
だからその子はゲームやっちゃう
まあこれが結局どう見たってもかっこ悪いねとかね
それで終わっちゃうし
ちょっとあ もうすごとかっこ悪いことやってますから
私たち別なことやります
そうすると あの かっこいいと言われてほしい人には
まあかっこ悪い かっこ悪い言われると
もう負けるしかないんですね
このトランプカード持ってるんだから
だからそういう風に子供が生まれてくると
いろいろトランプを持ってますよ
そこはどちら出せばいいかっていうこと
それを親の仕事なんです
それをしっかりした親になるんです
それで私は具体的にアドバイスしてもうまくいかない
なぜならば 一人一人の子供はもう自分の
特色を持ってますからね
それであの勉強したりすることに自信がなくなっちゃう場合も
ゲームに逃げるということもありますね
それもその子供によって違いますよ
勉強したいんだけど なんか自信がない
怒られるわ もうダメダメと言われるわね
これ間違ってるで そう言われると気持ち悪くなっちゃってね
じゃあゲームやるという風になっちゃう場合もあります
だからどういうところかと
そこを調べて 勉強しましょうという風に持っていかなくちゃいけないんです
あるいは遊びはゲームだけじゃないんだよと
これでどんどんまるまる太ったりしてね
動かなくなりますよと
あんた自転車に乗れなくなる
指だけですから 動いてるの？とかね
ああ 気持ち悪いとかね
あんたに力あるのはもう指だけでしょうにとかね
お父さんはもう走ったり回ったり
自転車に乗っていろいろやっても力あるでしょ
ほら 見てみろと できればあんた
お父さんの小指でもね
負けてみなさいとかね
ただ いや 負けようと思っても負けませんからね
子供に力がないんだから
ほら 見て そういうなんとかね
もうまた別なこともあるんだよという風にね
気持ちを変えなくちゃいけない
人生は楽しくなければ何もうまくいかないんだからダメとかね
やめなさいとかね ああいう風に決めない人生暗くなっちゃうんですね
勉強も楽しくするのは
まあ教育者の仕事でもありますけど
まあまあ 日本の教育者は忙しいんですからね
業務的なことでね 教える暇がないんです
で 子供の面倒見る暇は全くないんですからね
だから親でも自分の子供のそこら辺はね
勉強好きになるように
楽しくなるように しなくちゃいけないんです
何でもハイハイじゃないんですよ
みんな小さい時は何でもハイハイでやりますからね
頭が悪すぎ で 子供に学ぶチャンスがなくなるんです
子供は子供なりに負け負けんと頑張りますから
例えばね まあゲーム買ってくださいって言ったら
まあポイントつけましょうと
100ポイント取ったら買ってあげると
まあいろいろいいこと
これやったら 1ポイントとか2ポイントとかね
あれこれやってポイント制度を決めたりしてね
じゃあ 100ポイントになったらまあまあ買ってあげるとかね
それで自分大人だからいろんなからくりして結構頑張らないとポイントが上がらないようにした
でもそれもうまくいきません
子供 子供すごいずるいんだから
もう戦ってきますよ だからそれが子育て
子育てなんですね お互いもうやり合って
なんとかそれ必ずもう大人が勝たなくちゃいけないんです
最終的には子供はしつけを受ける側だから
子供に負けたらダメなんですね
はいはいと言ったら 何でもこれ欲しいとかね
子供必要でもないのにこれおもちゃどう？とかね
ある日 日曜日おもちゃ買おうと
まあ他の子供のためにね
日曜日っていうのはヨドバシのおもちゃ館っていうのは面白いんです
すごい面白いんです おもちゃ好きな男たちだから
いろんな男たちが入ってるんですね
もう老人からちっちゃな子供までね
みんな口を開けていろんなおもちゃを選びながら
まあそこは一応一人で来る場合はね
この二十歳ぐらいの人々とかは
まあかなりちょっとオタクたちでね
まああまり色が良くないんだけど
そちらにも若いお父さんたちが息子たち連れてくるんですね
あれ見てごらん 楽しいんですね
お父さんも男だから やっぱりおもちゃには興味ある
子供たちにも興味ある
だからそこで興味の仲間
同じ仲間ですね しかし
私はチェックするのはこれで買うのかというと買わないんですね
いろいろもう二人で三人で勉強するんで
これはこういうことで
こういうことで そうですね
じゃあ次のものに出て
それでそれとかね お父さんの興味あるものは子供に見せたりして
子供はそれ見てお父さん知らないこと
これはこうこうなりますよと
それで終わってとか まあ探検ですね
だからもしこの父親がね
まあ子供の機嫌を取ろうと思って買っちゃえばダメだよと私も思ったりするんですね
やっぱりしっかりしてる場合は
それぞれもう思い存分調べて
もうもう遊べるところはもう遊んで諦めちゃって
それで疲れたらじゃあ帰りましょうと
何ももう買わないで帰るんですね
あれでは楽しいと思いますね
だから親に父親にしても
子供と過ごす時間っていうのは一日しかないし
それで結構コミュニケーションも取れるし
そこで悪い子たちがいきなりキャーってこれ欲しいやと言って座り込んだり泣きわめいたりして
で それで子供の方が性格悪いんですね
それで私はチェックするのは親がこの問題どう解決するのかと
買ったら親の負け しかし子供はもう泣いてるんです
そこの勝負なんですよ
ダメとか言ったってもね
買ってあげませんからと言ったってもね
問題解決したわけじゃないんです
ある子供が私にお願いしたんですね
お母さんに言ってくださいと
犬を飼いたいんだと で
私が言ったら買ってくれるんだと
だから それなりの子供は子供なりにまあ頑張るでしょう
そこでまあで 私は親が買ってあげたくないという気持ちは知っている
私はどうしても親の味方しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからといって子供と嫌な気分も作りたくない
じゃあどう言えばいいんですかと
だから一生のお願いだからということで
あ なるほど じゃあ一生のお願いでしょ
じゃあ言いますと しかし
私は言いますから 一生だよ
それから何も本人の好きなもの
またリストはあります
あれもダメになります
お願いできませんよと
クリスマスのプレゼントはダメになっちゃいますよとかね
これもあれもこれもこれでいいと思う
あんた今小さいんだけどね
これからもう１２ ４ ５ 6
になるとね 自転車必要になるし
オートバイ全部ダメ それでいい
じゃあ言いますよと 一生のお願いだからね
だからまあ言葉の使い方はね
そんなに子供は知ってるわけじゃないし
そこでちょこっと弱みがね
見えるでしょ だからもう話が終了
で 本人本気であ そうです
それはまずいんですね
じゃあ諦めましょうと
だから子供に選択肢があなた一生いろいろ親におねだりする権利持つか
全てチャラにするか それだったら犬が欲しいことがもう諦めた方が自分が得するでしょうに
だからすごく気持ちよくまあ諦めたんです
だからそんなに子育てにそんなにすごく面白いんですよね
すっごく面白いんです
それで子供にも面白いし
人生はいろんな工夫しなくちゃいけないし
子供にしても結構いろんなことをして
親の機嫌を取って 自分好きなものをどうやってもらうのかとかね
はい そういうことで 一応あの子供でもちゃんとした性格を持ってる人間でしょうしね
しかしこの世の中のこと何も知らないんだからね
親がそこをすごい子供のことを心配して育てるという義務があるし
だからといって能力はないし
それで同時に親が 子供が親を育ててくれるんです
そしてそれは毎日宿題は出しますよ
全部ものすごいとんでもない宿題でしょうね
簡単な軽いものを出しません
もうたまげた宿題ばっかり出すので
それ一つも負けてはならないんです
軽い軽いことの場合は
まあちょこちょこちょこちょこと負けてもね
100円程度のものとかね
で 決して食べさせて食べさせることはないんだけど
まあソフトクリーム食べたくなったとかね
まあまあいいやとかね
だから言って毎回毎回はね
それはもう 基本的には負けてはならないんです
親っていうのは完璧に負けていることに気づかないんですね
小さい時はよく泣きますね
あれ すごい攻撃なんですね
怒りです 怒りで泣くんですね
親は子供は怒りで泣いていると思いたくないでしょ
悲しくて泣いてるんだと
赤ちゃんはしょうがないんですけど
赤ちゃん以外は泣くことに負けてはならんです
はい 泣いてる間はもう問題は喋りませんという風に
まあ一応中止にしなくちゃいけないんです
ある日 新宿駅で見たんですけど
子供が抱っこしなさいとね
泣いてて お母さんだけでしたけど
お母さんどこへ行って帰ってすごく疲れているのは目々なんですね
子供は歩けますけど 子供は歩きたくない
お母さんにはもう抱っこしていける力はないんです
お父さんいたならばもう抱っこしてあげてもいいんですけどね
やっぱり女一人ではね
突然この子とあの新宿駅がもう震えるぐらい泣き出した
何十万人も人がもう動いている場所で
それで終わらない 座り込んだんです
勝てるのかと その攻撃には人が行くわけものすごいでしょう
それでドーンと座って
みんなもう大人人間だからね
踏んだりはしませんだけどね
それでも小さな子供でしょうに
私は行きながらこのお母さんどんな態度取るのかとかね
いつもいるんですよ 今もう戦い
親と子が でも負けてはいけないんですよ
その場合は お母さんが
負けたらしつけにならない
そのお母さんもまあちょっとあまりにも人々いるんだから気が利いたかどうか分かりませんだけど
あるいは自然放送かもしれませんだけど
もう何もしないでそこら辺でじっと待ってるんです
子供置いていくわけにもいきませんし
じっと待ってるんです
子供はいくらか泣いて周りチェックしますから
どうですかね 戦いもこっちは爆弾を撃ちまくったんだからね
向こうは倒れているのか見たら倒れてるとお母さんいないんですね
見えないでしょうね これでギャーッと不安になっちゃって
お母ちゃーんと泣きながらまた走ってくる
はい 行きましょう 抱っこしようともうそんな話しないです
そこでお母さんの勝ちなんですね
だからそれでなんであんなに泣くのか
それはもうそれは子供の世界だからね
じゃあ行きましょうとか
何のことなく親切に 何もなかったように感じで
そういうふうな微妙な仕事をやらなくちゃいけないんです
これからは 頑張ってください
すみません ビッカベーという言葉の解釈をちょっとお尋ねしたいんですが
ビッカベー 比丘たちよというお釈迦様がですね
比丘たちよっておっしゃった時は
それは比丘だけじゃなくて在家の信者も含めるんだというような噂をちょっと聞いたんですよね
それまあわからないこともないんですけども
ただあの経典なんか読んでますと
トゥンヘイビッカベーとおっしゃったりとかですね
そういう風にあの子も限定してるような感じでおっしゃったりとか
あるいは立道の中ですと
これを許可しますとか
これを否定しますというふうに
ビッカベーというふうにおっしゃってるんですよね
ですから絶対にそれ在家も含めて考えるっていうのは言えないんじゃないかなと思ったんですけども
その辺の解釈はどうなんでしょうか
私の個人的な解説は この比丘と言ったってもね
在家の人は聞くなよという意味はないことは誰でも知ってますから
誰が聞いたってもいいんだけど
あえてビッカベーと呼んで喋る場合は
お釈迦様は一応待機説法だから
もしかすると比丘たちが必ず理解しなくちゃいけないというね
ニュアンスが入ってるんじゃないかなと
もう義務で比丘だから出家だからね
わがままを言う権利はなくて
これはこれでこれでこれで理解しなさいよというね
そこは在家の人々も聞いて悟りましたというならば
それはまあもう別なついて
なんて言いますか おまけの結果で
在家の人々に何々ガハパタヨとか何々サンヨとか呼ぶ場合は
その人の性格に理解に合わせて持っていくんですね
その人が悟れるようにと
ビッカベーという場合は
ほとんど中身は仏教真理そのものなんですね
あんまり性格的に合わせていろいろ言ったりすることはないんですね
ですから この待機説法といえば待機説法なんですけど
まあそれほど他の人々のことよりも
比丘たちが完全に理解してもらうことはもう選定しているんじゃないかなと思いますね
そこで比丘たち以外関係ない話
例えば戒律の場合はもう関係ない
明らかに比丘サンガの世界で
経典では関係ないわけじゃないんですね
例えば中部経典のこの 第3セットに入っている最後の経典
いくつかあります もうまあ大体五
六ぐらいありますけど
かなり内容は難しいし
はっきりとテーマを決めてますね
もう最後の悟りに達するために
どのように心を持っていって
どのように観察するべきかということ
これをもうセットフレーズでいろいろ経典に入れてありますね
その場合は明確にもう相手は決まっているというね
だから 中身による判断するか
中身で まあ五蘊は無常であるという場合は比丘用と言うんですね
でも在家の人の場合も五蘊は無常ですけど
で 無常たるものは苦でありますよ
苦たるものは我として認めてはならんでしょうと語る場合は
仏教の専門的な知識でしょうにね
その場合は 呼ぶ相手は比丘になるんですね
例えばエータ 比丘カーラーマーとカーラーマーさんたちでね
もう伝統であるんだから真理じゃないとかね
人に聞いたんだからと言って信じるなよとかね
理屈に合うからと言って信じるなかれとかね
疑いなさいと思い存分とかね
私は沙門で釈尊で有名だからといって抱かれて信じるなよということを自分たちで調べなさいよという場合は
もうカーラーマーさん
しっかりとカーラーマーさんに合わせて喋っているんですね
カーラーマーさんが初めから疑い深い人間でしたから
はい これでよしと疑いなさい
うのみにするなよという態度から始まるんです
それで君たちで判断しなさい
ところでいきなり欲はいいことですかと聞くんですね
欲に染めた人が良いことをするか悪いことをする
どう思う？お釈迦様は欲に汚染した人はより悪いことでしょうと
では 君たちは欲に汚染する行為はやめた方がいいと思う？やった方がいいと
それはやめた方がいいに決まってるでしょうにと
では 欲に欲から離れた人がやってる行為は良いこと？悪いこと？欲から離れてるならやってることは良いことに決まってるでしょうと
じゃあそういうのはやった方がいいとはやめた方がいい
いや これはやった方がいいんだよと
それで貪瞋痴まで言って
結局は本人決めるんで
殺生してはいかんとかね
盗ってはいかんと お釈迦様
ほら 私が決めてないでしょうにと
あなた方が決めてるんだよと
そんな風に比丘たちよと言っては喋りません
そんな親切じゃないんです
その程度の差はありますね
比丘たちの場合も 相手本当に個人の比丘がいる場合は
また親切になるんです
その場合は大体名前で呼びますけど
で 比丘であっても名前で呼んで喋る場合はもう優しいんです
その人にしっかり理解できるようなプロセスで喋るんです
もう普通名詞で比丘となっちゃうと
もうちょっと経典の中身は厳しい
あれは授業ような感じなんですね
講義 一つの授業 おとなしく聞きなさいと
だから教えは全部在家出家関係ないんだからね
基本的仏教教えはね 生命に対する教えですからね
立正の場合はもう在家の方々には何の関係もないんです
[背景音楽]長部経典の一番ブラフマジャーラ経典にしても
まあビッカウェイなんですけど
中身はもう非常にあり得る
起こり得る 一切宗教哲学を分析するんです
だからその時点で中身は厳しいんだけど
在家の人々の役に立ちますよ
勉強できれば 長い経典の中では
この流れで順番で次第説法はなりますけど
どんどん出家する話になるんですね
仙妻三袖で出家して それからこういうこういう戒律を持って
四種の戒律を持って それから瞑想を始めて
禅定に入って それからもう悟りに達するというね
その場合はやっぱり出家のプログラムになりますね
人は皆 誰でも出家しなさいという話は毛頭ないんだからね
次第説法する場合は比丘たちに普通の道徳から始まります
それは出家さえどちらでもいいんです
それは在家の人もこれ学ぼうかなと思ったところで
どんどんここまで理解した人は仙妻三袖て
それもう髪の毛を剃って出家するんだぞ
出家しましょうとかね
このすごい梵行を在家のままでは実践できませんというので
それはもう比丘たち用と喋っている経典の場合なんですね
比丘たちがもうとっくに出家はしているし
あの在家に出家ほのめかす話はお釈迦様はしません
で お釈迦様の話 時々比丘たちに言ってる説法とか何とか聞いて聞いてた在家の人が
これはもうすごい教え
もうやらなくちゃいけないぞ
完璧にやるためには出家